pas question pour emmanuel macron de
laisser une lenteur injustifiée
s'installer c'est en tout cas ce que le
chef de l'état avait assuré à lors de
ses voeux aux français le soir de la
saint-sylvestre le chef de l'état qui
s'est dit irrité selon nos confrères du
jdd face à la tournure que prend cette
campagne de vaccination il a donc
présidé une réunion à de suivi ce lundi
autour de lui le premier ministre mais
aussi à des ministres en première ligne
sur le front de la vaccination
l'exécutif qui doit faire face aux
critiques sur le lent démarrage de cette
campagne de vaccination il faut dire que
le pays accuse un réel retard par
rapport à ses voisins européens au 1er
janvier en france on comptait 116
personnes vaccinées à titre de
comparaison l'allemagne a administré
plus de 200 ou deux doses de vaccin à
ses concitoyens au royaume uni à près
d'un million de personnes ont déjà été
vaccinées soit alors que la plupart des
pays européens ont débuté à leur
campagne de vaccination au même moment
le 27 décembre dernier
en visite à l'hôtel à l'hôtel dieu à
paris cet après midi
ministre de la santé a promis une montée
en puissance je vous propose d'écouter
danse et déjà je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous aurons réalisé
plusieurs milliers de vaccination dans
tout le pays
ça va monter en puissance et ça montera
encore plus en puissance à partir de
mercredi jeudi vendredi la fin de
semaine
quant aux ehpad la vaccination se
poursuit de façon progressive avec une
chaîne logistique que nous devons
absolument respecter un pour ne pas
gâcher de doses deux pour ne pas faire
l'impasse sur la sécurité
absolument indispensable pour pouvoir
réaliser cette campagne vaccinale dans
de bonnes conditions nous aurons un
million de doses disponibles d'ici la
fin de semaine entre promesses
l'ouverture de centres de vaccination en
ville avant le début du mois de février
puis outre cette réunion à de suivi
aujourd'hui un conseil de défense et un
conseil de ministres des ministres
devrait se dérouler mercredi noter aussi
qu'à partir de demain les autorités
sanitaires ferons un point quotidien sur
l'avancée de la campagne de vaccination
et puis c'est aussi aujourd'hui qu'a
débuté le tirage au sort des 35 français
qui formeront un conseil un citoyen ce
dernier pour interpeller l'exécutif sur
sa stratégie vaccinale